So the first thing we'll do, is add all the links
that we find on the page that we're crawling, that's the
value of page, to to crawl. The best way to do
that is to use the union procedure, that we defined in an
earlier quiz this unit, that will avoid having duplication in to
crawl. If you didn't use union, you could still get the stork.
It's okay if there's duplication because we're doing this test to
not crawl the same page twice. So I'll do it using union.
We're going to union into to crawl. The results of
finding all the links on the page that we found, and
we need to use get page passing in page to
get the actual contents of that page. And the get all
links procedure that we defined earlier returns a list of
all the links on that page. The next thing we need
to do, is to keep track of the pages that we've
crawled, we can do that by using append. So that adds
this page to the list of pages we've crawled, and
now we're done. We've got a working web crawler, for any
seed page, it will find all the pages that can
be reached from that page, and return them in a list.